[Музика]
[Музика] Відео
Девіда Чітіна hojae Адачі Міна
або лідерство в аджиліті прийшли
добре, хлопці, я радий бачити вас знову, і
я був крутий, тому сьогодні у мене є двоє спеціальних
гостей, перш за все, зустріч мого колегу
пана.  Павло, він збирається читати урок
зі мною сьогодні, і чи не могли б ви зустрітися з
нашим зірковим гостем сьогодні Діма, я дуже радий
, що ви сьогодні
тут, дуже дякую, я також радий бути тут,
дякую за уроки для вашої
роботи  і я думаю, що це буде дуже гарно провести
час так, Павло, ти можеш розповісти
трохи про себе, будь ласка, так, як
сказала Ольга, я працюю з Ольгою, я
вчитель англійської мови і вчитель фізкультури, і я
жив в Україні 10 років, добре, так
хлопці, ми починаємо першу дію, зараз ви
побачите деякі слова на екрані, і
вони розташовані не в правильному порядку, ви
повинні розмістити ці слова, щоб створити
фрази, які вам знадобляться для
розмови, і вам потрібно додати
знак питання, якщо  потрібен, звісно,
діловий знак, якщо потрібно, то
у уважно подивіться на ці ре
ення ммм добре, так що перше, то що
нас є, у нас є якийсь клуб, як пр
, будь ласка, ін
ормація про дзюдо, добре, яке до
ге речення, боже мій Діма  ви
спантеличені, це невелика проблема, я можу
робити так, як мені подобається, але я не знаю, я хотів
би трохи
я хотів би трохи інформації про clop
так, тому Пол це правильно, давайте подивимося, я хотів
би отримати інформацію про клуб дзюдо,
будь ласка, о так, так, будь ласка, нам
потрібно бути  ввічливо добре, що про магію бородавку
так добре, так що наступний досить
простий правильно я сподіваюся, так що
я спробую це так,
дякую за надію, так, в основному, Павло,
дякую за вашу допомогу.
щодо наступного
, довше, принесіть якийсь особливий du
Clos цей i2, тож, можливо, мені доведеться
закрити особливе, Пол, це правильно, давайте
подивимося, чи маю я принести спеціальний одяг,
який правильний, мій одяг так, так добре,
наступний, він коштує багато
скільки це коштує так швидко Пол я думаю, що
він може бути правий
скільки це коштує це правильно,
останній готовий так добре,
ви можете допомогти як я я я я ніби ні
я  Я, як майстер Йода,
так, як і знову зібрати всі слова,
але добре,
що правильне, як я можу  допоможіть вам
Павло, що правий, можливо, знову буде правий.
Привіт, як я можу вам
допомогти.  Пол
добре, тому Павло перший я хотів би отримати
інформацію про клуб дзюдо,
будь ласка, другий, дякую за
вашу допомогу,
привіт наступний, чи потрібно мені принести
спеціальний одяг, а четвертий, скільки
це коштує, і номер п'ять, як можна  Я
вам допомагаю добре ні ми готові
слухати діалоги і слухати рекламу
Павло, що це виглядає як
важке завдання для Діми о да насправді
це не так це оголошення, яке Павло побачив
у газеті, тому Павло йде  щоб
прочитати це оголошення
Діма, ти можеш побачити дівчину
правильно так добре, не поспішайте, і якщо вам
потрібна ручка і олівець або олівець, і
якщо вам потрібно щось записати, ви
можете, щоб Павло прочитав оголошення і ви повинні
заповнити пропуски  з правильною
інформацією
добре добре я спробую добре ви готові Deema
так добре Київ відкрита Jim teen zone для
підлітків 12-17 років понеділок
середа і п'ятниця з 8:00 до 20:00
300 грн за місяць
спробуйте CrossFit Zoomer і важка атлетика
ок
Діма треба ще
раз послухати ой можна добре хлопці
ми послухаємо ще раз Київ
відкрита тренажерна зона для підлітків
12-17 років понеділок середа  та п'ятниця з
8:00 до 20:00
300 грн на місяць
спробуйте CrossFit Zuma і важка атлетика
добре так що Діма так хлопці ви готові
тому мені потрібно повторити це правильно так
чи не могли б ви прочитати це ага,
кию відкрити тренажерний зал підліткова зона для підлітків
від 12 до 7 до 17 років привіт  мій
відкритий в понеділок середа і п'ятниця
понеділок середа і п'ятниця нормально з 8
ранку до 20 вечора
добре 300 грн 4 на місяць спробуйте CrossFit
і вони займаються підняттям тягарів
давайте перевіримо, тому ось правильні
відповіді, хлопці,
тепер ви побачите, чи все добре зробив Діма,
добре, так що Діма відмінно 17 понеділків
середа 8 ранку 300 гривень
CrossFit так добре, добре ми  можна продовжити і рухатися
далі, ось діалог, уявіть, що
ви хочете піти до SportsCenter, і
вам потрібно зателефонувати на ресепшн і
запитати про інформацію, діяльність
така сама. Я збираюся читати цей
діалог разом з паном.  Пол і ви
повинні заповнити прогалини
інформацією, якої зараз не вистачає, але
ми прочитаємо її вголос для вас, а потім
спробуємо розіграти майже той самий
діалог, добре, хлопці, ви готові,
тож, Пол, ви збираєтеся  будь на
ресепшн або Ешлі я буду
секретаркою, будь ласка, Ольга однозначно
вибрала найсильнішого вчителя англійської мови в
Україні, тоді я буду Ешлі
добре давайте почнемо добрий день
це Київ відкритий спортзал добрий день я хочу отримати
інформацію, будь ласка,
звичайно, як можна  Я вам допомагаю Я вважаю, що у
вас є уроки кросфіту в Спортивному
центрі, які є уроками
для дітей та
підлітків від 12 до 17 років.
кожен урок триває півтори
години з 8 ранку до 20 вечора
ага скільки вони коштували це безкоштовно
сотню гривень на місяць
добре дякую за допомогу ласкаво просимо
дякую що зателефонував ладно так Діма
ти отримав всю інформацію ой треба
послухати ще раз думаю
це слухай  до цього ще раз впевнений
ще раз тільки ще раз добре добре
так ще раз Павло добрий день
це Київ відкритий спортзал добрий день я хотів
би отримати інформацію, будь ласка,
звичайно, чим я можу вам допомогти я вірю, що у
вас є уроки кросфіту в спортивному
Центр, який є уроками
для дітей та підлітків
віком від 12 до 17 років. О, чудово, які
дні йдуть уроки в понеділок і
четвер, чи можете ви сказати мені, о котрій годині вони
, кожне заняття триває півтори
години та  з 8:00 до 20:00
угу, скільки вони коштують
це 300 гривень на місяць добре дякую
за допомогу, ласкаво просимо, дякую
за дзвінок привіт, мамо, я думаю, я зрозумів,
я думаю, що я отримав це, тепер
твоя черга, так що добре  і мій секретар
або мій Еш Лі, ви повинні обговорити це з
паном.  Містер.  Пол, ти б хотів бути
реєстратором Австралії, добре, так що
я буду Ешлі добре, хлопці, починайте, добрий
день, це Київ відкритий спортзал, добрий
день, я хотів би отримати інформацію,
будь ласка,
як я можу вам допомогти Я вважаю, що у
вас є кросфіт  уроки в
спортивному центрі, які є уроками
для дітей та підлітків
віком від 12 до 17 років. О, чудово,
які дні проводяться в
понеділок і четвер, чи можете ви сказати мені, чи можете
ви розповісти мені, що
це за кожен урок  триває півтори
години з 8 ранку до 20 вечора
О, скільки вони коштують, це 300
гривень на місяць добре, дякую за
допомогу, ласкаво просимо, дякую, що
подзвонили, хлопці, це було чудово,
дякую, зараз давайте перевіримо, чи
все добре у Діми, тому залишайте відкритим тренажерний зал, але
хлопці, коли ви  Ви телефонуєте до Спортивного
центру, назва може бути різною, наприклад,
палиці, наприклад, палиці Viva і poo, тоді вас
може зацікавити не тільки кросфіт,
але й інші види спорту, тому ви можете
замінити це слово на будь-який інший вид
спорту, який вас цікавить, наприклад
брейк-данс, можливо, все просто танці чи
щось інше, тоді тут вас можуть
зацікавити заняття для різних вікових
груп, можливо, ви хочете, щоб ваша мама чи
навіть бабуся чи дідусь ходили в
спортзал, тоді вам буде цікава вікова
група, а не 12 і  17
добре, тоді ді-джеї, що уроки, щоб
ви могли говорити понеділок, вівторок, вихідні, що
завгодно, щоб ви могли змінити цю
інформацію на тривалість
уроку.
як ти
тренуєшся і скільки тривають твої тренування. У
мене є тренування. У мене
на телефоні мій персональний тренер,
а мої щоденні тренування тривають приблизно
годину, а не години, а не півтори мм-
хм.  будинок для мене це занадто багато
, тому що в моєму житті багато танцюристів
, багато виступів і
подорожей, тому нам потрібно зберігати
енергію, так, так, і вони можуть бути схожими
на часовий пояс, який може відрізнятися,
як не від  Тільки з 8:00 до
20:00  вони можуть початися раніше або
пізніше ціни, а також голими очима, тому
300 breena - це просто ми вдавали, що
це так, ціна може бути
іншою, добре, хлопці, ви готові це
практикувати, але без цього діалогу
Діма Пол ви готові
давайте спробуємо  добре знищити добре, хлопці,
давайте готуймося добре, але перед цим
ось банк мовлення, а ось
корисні вирази, які можуть допомогти вам
вести цю бесіду, чи
можете ви вгадати, які фрази всі вони були
в діалозі, який ви прочитали раніше, добре,
Дерек, чи можете ви вгадати  перший я
хотів би мати деяку інформацію, будь ласка,
о, просто я хотів би трохи я б хотів трохи
інформації добре, я можу зробити другий,
як я можу вам допомогти,
добре, пан.  Павло, а третій
, можливо, ти можеш сказати мені
, о котрій годині вони в порядку Діма чи вони вони викликають скільки
вони коштують
правильно скільки вони коштують гм,
ласкаво просимо і дякую, що зателефонували добре,
давайте прочитаємо їх ще раз після Mr.
Павло, я хотів би отримати інформацію, будь ласка,
чим я можу вам допомогти, чи можете ви сказати мені,
скільки вони, скільки вони коштують
, ласкаво просимо, дякую за дзвінок,
добре, зараз готовність 100% до
діалогу ми йдемо, тому практика робить вас ідеальними
вам доведеться використовувати діаграму для підготовки
іншого діалогу, хлопці, ви можете змінити
інформацію, зараз намагайтеся не дотримуватися
діалогу, який ми читали раніше, тому знову і знову у
нас є секретар, а ви
людина, яка збирається зателефонувати в спортивний
центр, щоб  Перша фраза звучить
від секретаря,
він або вона відповідає на телефон. Я
даю назву тренажерного залу. Зроблено це ваша
реакція, ви кажете, що вам потрібна
інформація,
потім секретар пропонує
допомогу, і ви запитали про уроки для
підлітків після цього  Адміністратор
говорить про вік класів, і під
все ще у вас є ще кілька запитань, які ви
повинні запитати про те, коли в них уроки,
дні та години
пам'ятайте про мавп або - четверга та
години, наприклад, 8 ранку чи 9 вечора
у будь-який час і в будь-який час, тоді
портье вказує вам дні та
час, а ви запитуєте про ціну
за уроки і готово, секретар
дає ціну, і ви закінчуєте
розмову, дякуючи і
прощаючись, так що, хлопці, можливо, ви можете
змінити ролі  добре, отже я є
секретарка читай, ти хочеш спробувати я
хотів би спробувати я боюся,
ми впораємось, так що привіт
це ритм-джем, як я можу вам допомогти
схуднення які у вас заняття ой
у нас є уроки важкої атлетики у
нас є кроссфіт у нас є брейк-данс
і у нас є йога йога для
схуднення ок нова програма звучить дуже
цікаво також чи можу я привести
дочку-підлітка які заняття ти займаєшся  є для
підлітків
о так, звичайно, у нас є заняття від
12 до 17 років, скільки років вашій дочці
моїй дочці 15. О, у нас є
заняття для неї,
і я пропоную запропонувати важку атлетику
та кросфіт та брейк-данс, я думаю, що
вона хотіла б  що їй це не сподобалося
їй це сподобається, їй
це сподобається добре, добре, я дам їй вашу
пораду, але у неї щільний графік,
багато домашніх завдань, чи не могли б ви сказати мені,
коли відбуватимуться уроки та які дні
зараз у п'ятницю, понеділок і
четвер і  це відразу після школи
о 17:00  прямо о 17:00, будь то о 17:00.
кожен урок за ці дні чудово
дякую за інформацію Діма але
моя донька завжди була підлітком, тому я
не маю стільки грошей скільки
це буде коштувати для неї це 300 рін
за кожен урок і я думаю, що це
не так  дорого
добре дякую дуже дякую,
ми чекаємо на вас до побачення добре,
хлопці, так вам сподобався ваш тип
вступу, вам сподобалося
о так, це дуже цікаво, дуже мені
потрібно більше практикувати англійську, мм-хм,
спілкуватися з  ми з вами розуміємо, що мені
потрібно більше практикувати англійську так,
тому що практика стає ідеальною,
якщо ви не практикуєте, тоді ви втрачаєте її,
хлопці,
англійська — це не знання Англійська — це не
наука Англійська — це вміння, яке вам потрібно
практикувати щодня, щоб бути
конкурентоспроможним  щоб досягти успіху в цьому добре, хлопці, тому
Mr.  опитування ти був дуже відповідальним
батьком, а Діма ти був непоганим
секретарем, хлопці, ти б хотів
помінятися ролями зараз цього разу Діма
ти клієнт, і ти дзвониш у
спортзал, а Павло ти там
підрід чи, можливо, спортзал  власник добре, так
почніть, привіт, це Пол з фітнес-
центром, як я можу вам допомогти, привіт, Павло
фітнес-центр, це я. Набридливий Клайн
ще раз я щойно подивився новий о ні,
я щойно подивився старий фільм, який
називався «Брудні танці», перша та друга
частини, і я вирішив  що я хочу
бути найкращим танцюристом, і я відповідаю
: чи є у вас у вашому тренажерному залі поглиблені заняття,
так, ми займаємося.
можливо, хаус-денс добре, всі наші
танцювальні заняття залежать від віку, чи можу я запитати
вас, скільки років людині, яка буде
танцювати, людині, яка буде танцювати
, приблизно 34 роки, але у мене є двоє дітей,
яким три та чотири роки
мати клас  s для них, щоб я міг
взяти їх із собою так, у нас є заняття
від підлітків аж до
дитячого садка, о, це чудово, і в які
дні наші заняття для
наймолодших дітей починаються о 12:00.
Понеділок, середа та п'ятниця, дуже дякую,
скільки тривають ці уроки, вам
потрібно сплатити щомісячну плату, і ця
місячна плата становить 300 гривень на місяць
о, це чудова ціна, мені подобається,
дуже дякую за інформацію.
думаю, ви ще раз чудово попрацювали
добре, хлопці, вам сподобалося, як
Діма та пан.  Пол працює під час цього
уроку
ні, ми майже в кінці цього
уроку, так повно, що це буде
за конкурс, який конкурс ми збираємося
дати дітям мм-хм, можливо, їм доведеться спробувати
і зробити те, що Діма зробив чудово, це
чудова ідея, тому, хлопці, ви б дотримувалися
цієї схеми, і чи не могли б ви створити
свій власний діалект, наприклад, якби ви
телефонували в цей бідний центр і
попросили уроки на рік, тому я ще раз
хочу нагадати вам цю схему, яку ви
повинні дотримуватися  звісно,
шій розмові має бути дві людини, та
має бути секретар, і ви, то
у секретар відповідає на дзвінок і д
є назву тренажерного залу, вигадуєте будь-яке ім
я, яке ви хочете, потім ви говорите свою ін
ормацію, ніж портье пропонує ва
допомогу, а ви  запитайте про уроки
для підлітків або для будь-якої іншої вікової групи,
пам'ятайте, Діма запитав про уроки
для своїх дітей трьох-чотирьох років,
а потім приймальник каже вам
вік і класи, тоді ви повинні
запитати ще раз або  але якщо вони
доступні в понеділок, вівторок чи
середу, то ви запитуєте, коли в
них уроки, і ви вказуєте дні і
час, тож тоді ціна та
прийоми дають ціну, і не
забудьте ввічливо закінчити розмову,
щоб зробити вигляд, що ви  ви на
ресепшн або прикинулися, що ви
дзвоните, насправді попросіть своїх друзів
підтримати вас і зняти відео,
опубліковане десь в Instagram на або на
tik-tok, ми будемо стежити за вами
і бачити ці відео, і побачимо, що
ви дивитеся на нас  і ти вчишся
з нами, тому сьогодні я був дуже щасливий,
що ти був у нашому класі, я був дуже
щасливий мати Mr.  Павло і Діма, хлопці, дякую вам
за цей чудовий урок,
велике спасибі, ласкаво просимо, дякую, дякую,
дякую, Mr.  Пол, дякую, Ольга,
дуже приємно, тому, хлопці, Белл
пішов
до вас наступного разу, коли Хорхе куляє корів,
ім'я, яке ми будемо різати, ідеально підходить для карате
та віскі Тім Бішоп Елвін,
але Hauraki — це Лондон, щоб подорожувати,
я впевнений, що ви помітили  Браух у Лондоні
втікає, і якщо ви зробите j-squad без наклейок,
відновіть його так,
давайте наведемо практичні інструкції, щоб зробити
акцент на вас стільки, скільки нам потрібно.
до Mr.  Поланський найкращий
президент мене добре Сото Англійська Англійська
ви знаєте, сам аналітик випуск
практики вони залишили життя зупиняє голос
шанс був більше на зйомках і
його з усього шляху це дуже
перетравлена форма і ескімоська так робить бі
а лама респіратор як що
о  Буддійська національна лінія рок
[музика]
you